so Zuck but I think we can all agree
Elon isn't serious and it's time to move
on I've offered a real date didn't y
often make this a legit competition for
a charity Elon won't confirm a date and
says he needs surgery and now has to do
a practice round in my backyard instead
if Elon ever gets serious about a real
date and official event he knows how to
reach me otherwise time to move on I'm
going to focus on competing with people
who take the sport seriously
what's up with Jeff Bezos
because I don't want to see Zuck fight
like you know legit Fighters like let's
let's go for these big big boys what's
Bill Gates do I'd love to see him choke
out Bill Gates yeah but Bill Gates is no
way in shape for that but so with Alex
Jones and Alex Jones Zuck fight wasn't
Alex a wrestler too I think he was in
high school or something like that I
don't think so I think so but I don't
think so dude